First thing I should say is that the math
community is a wonderful community.
We take joy in what we do, and we love helping
people see the world through a mathematical
lens.
At the same time I would say that we suffer
from the same problems that maybe our broader
culture does.
We often idolize achievements, and we think
that — the problem with that is that you
end up thinking that only certain people,
if they're going to achieve at the highest
levels, belong in mathematics.
It would be like in saying in music saying
that music is only for the Beethovens and
the Bachs, rather than saying that everybody
can enjoy music and everyone can create music.
What happens then in mathematics, if you fall
into that trap, is that you end up thinking
that certain people are math people and certain
people aren't math people.
Bias can creep in.
We can inadvertently start shepherding some
people to math and other people not to math.
And I would say: No.
Math is for everybody.
Math helps everybody flourish, no matter what
profession you end up in.
Everybody should learn and enjoy more math.